what advice would you give to people
that are in their 30s are entering their
30s about how to operate in life I think
every person in their 20s and 30s should
lift heavy weights and run long
distances in their brain and in the gym
push yourself really hard how old are
you 34. you look like a beast and in 20
years you're just going to look back on
how strong you were and just marvel at
it and you're going to wish as strong as
you were that you even push yourself
harder just when you think you can't
take any more that means you're about a
third of the way to your limits as a
human my first job was a Morton Stanley
an investment bank I was undereducated
relative to my peer group so I decided
every Tuesday morning I was going to
come into work and I wasn't going to
leave till Wednesday night and I'm like
I can do that I'm physically really
strong I'm mentally really strong and it
sent a signal to the rest of the
organization that I came to play develop
that kind of grit and strength
emotionally physically and
intellectually in your 20s and 30s
you're capable of it you're just going
to look back on that Aaron just marvel
it out and control strong you are both
mentally and physically